So, let's suppose you got a bunch of emails that, some of them came from me, and
some of them came from Sebastian.
We might have a lot of overlap.
We might both be talking about machine learning and Udacity.
But some of them are going to be talking about, let's say physics.
Because that's what my background is in.
And that's going to be comparatively rare.
There's not going to be tons and
tons of emails in that corpus that are talking about physics.
Because most all of Sebastian's are, don't talk about physics at all.
It's only going to be mine.
And then likewise,
maybe there's a bunch of emails that talk about Stanley the robot.
Which of course is one of his projects, but
not something that I'm a real expert in.
So, the fact that words like physics and Stanley would be rare in this corpus,
compared to words like Udacity or machine learning.
Means that these might be the words that tell you the most important
information about what's going on.
Who might be the author of a given message?
And so, another way to think about that is that this is why it's called
the inverse document frequency.
That you want to weight the words by inverse of how often they
appear in the corpus as a whole.
I'm not going to have you code an example of Tf Idf right now, as a quiz.
But this is something that we're going to cover in
the mini project that's coming up very shortly, at the end of this lesson.
So, you will get your hands dirty with this representation a little bit.